2021
on the other hand
which includes
foreign
it's essential
um
for extensive use of boosters in all
adults
[Music]
and work together to support those who
are furthest behind
today the doubleh strategic advisory
group of experts on immunization or sage
is issuing an interim statement on
booster dose
sage concluded that the focus of
immunization must remain on decreasing
deaths and severe disease
and expressed concern that blanket
booster programs will exacerbate vaccine
inequity
about 20 percent of all vaccine doses
administered every day are currently
being given as boosters
or additional dose
blanket booster programs are likely to
prolong the pandemic
rather than ending it
by diverting supply to countries that
already have high levels of vaccination
coverage
giving the virus more opportunity to
spread and mutate
it's important to remember that the vast
majority of hospitalizations and deaths
are in unvaccinated people
not
unboosted people
and we must be very clear that the
vaccines we have
remain effective against both the delta
and omicron variants
the global priority must be to support
all countries to reach the 40 percent
target as quickly as possible
and the 70 percent target by the middle
of this year
no country can boost its way out of the
pandemic
and boosters cannot be seen as a ticket
to go ahead with the planned
celebrations
without the need for other precautions
even as we work to make the best use of
vaccines we have
doublyho is also working to identify the
next generation of vaccines through the
solidarity trial
vaccines the solidarity trial vaccines
is co-sponsored by wha and the
ministries of health of colombia
mali and philippines
and aims to accelerate the evaluation of
more covid19 vaccines to expand the
portfolio and improve access
it's also intended to uncover second
generation vaccines
with greater protection against variants
of concern
with longer duration of protection
or to us as vaccines that can be given
without
needles
the vaccines in the trial were selected
by an independent advisory group of
leading scientists and experts
research teams in colombia mali and
philippines began recruiting volunteers
in late september
and so far
over 11
500 people are participating in the
trial
so far
the trial includes two vaccines three
others will be included shortly and more
can be included
who invites all countries
and research centers to participate in
this trial
2021 has been a painful year for many of
us
but
we cannot allow it to be a waste year
as we approach a new year
we must all learn the painful lessons
this year told us
2022
must be the end of the coveted 19
pandemic
but
it must also be the beginning of
something else
a new era of solidarity
we must leave 2021 behind with sorrow
and look forward to 2022 in hope
on that note
i would like to wish all who celebrated
a very merry
christmas
merry christmas
christian back to you
thank you very much director general let
me now open the floor to questions from
the journalists and again to remind you
although we have a very long list
already if you want to raise your hand
to ask questions please raise your hand
i can and when you call upon you please
unmute yourself
we'll start with sophie moquina from
south african broadcasting sophie please
unmute yourself
thank you so much
my question is directed to the officials
dr pedro's
dr van keckoff and dr ryan
i just want to find out
with
the world
commemorating
two years next week on the 31st of
december
since china
reported the corona virus
where are we
as the world in terms of fighting
this
coronavirus and
the variance are we beginning to
understand
the behavior of variance
and that we step ahead or we are still
struggling
[Music]
yeah sophia i think
thank you we didn't get everything but i
hope the crying child was not a sign for
2021 um maybe we'll start with dr maria
van kerkov
sophie thanks uh very much for your
really um very good question very
insightful question and
um i mean i think
two years into this pandemic
we are
well trained
we understand
this invisible pathogen
that is you know causing complete havoc
in all of our lives
we have the upper hand in terms of what
we need to do to be able to control it
we have tools that can bring it to its
knees
that could save lives countless lives
what is unclear to me as we enter into
2022 is how we use those tools to
actually end this
i'm very hopeful into the third year of
this pandemic that we could actually
bring this virus under control
i think it is a formidable enemy
um but i think we have an entire global
army forgive the uh military
reference there but i think we have an
entire globe of people who know what
they need to do to end this i think we
just really need to come together to do
that
um we have uh health workers who are
exhausted
but who have been tremendous
over the last two years and even before
that of course in terms of keeping
people safe and caring for our loved
ones
we have a public that knows what they
need to do
and in some respects you know they just
need to take some difficult decisions to
make sure that they limit their exposure
to this virus
we have governments that know
that they need a comprehensive approach
to tackle covid19
so i'm very hopeful
my concern remains of whether or not we
have the stamina to really
put in the effort to end it and i think
we can
so
um there's a lot more to do i i do
believe we're still in the middle of
this pandemic unfortunately
but i completely believe that we have
the the power to end it in 2022.
so vaccine equity and and getting the
vaccines to those who need them most in
all countries must be a priority for
every single government
not just some
we need to also be able to use tools to
drive transmission down because if we
don't we will continue to see the virus
change and the virus threaten us in ways
that will bring us closer to the
beginning rather than closer to the end
so i choose uh to use my energy and the
energy of all of the the experts that
work with us around the world
to bring us closer to the end in 2022
and i think all of us can do that
thank you dr van kerkov and uh seeing if
maybe dr ryan
wants to come into this
sorry for putting you on the spot in
case
christian no i was just listening to
maria there i i i um
i think we have real hopes of doing
better next year especially
when we see
governments like that of um
uh south africa that's one of those
under the huge
transparency that they showed in dealing
with the unicorn variant and and the
power of science surveillance and public
health
in southern africa
has really given us given us real
important lead time uh for the rest of
the world to prepare for all the spread
of homicide we will see
further variance and what we really need
is
to have a more sustainable strategies
that are agile and flexible and
adjustable and scalable
and that we're not lurching from doing
nothing to doing full lockdowns we seem
to be in a cycle of
hoping that it's over you know putting
our hands over our ears
and uh
and then going from that sort of
ignoring the problem to uh
shutting down society so i do think and
i hope that we have
more sustainable
adjustable strategies and we've seen
that in many asian countries many asian
countries haven't fully locked down at
any point during this pandemic if i
recall singapore at no point has closed
with schools um kept universities and
other things open and made the
priorities of the society
for what society needs to remain open
for example like schools and then
trading off where
physical distance social physical or
public health and social measures need
to be more intense so i i do think we're
not at the end of this pandemic we're
not even close
we have the tools as maria said better
tools than we've ever had before thanks
to science we have a much better
understanding about how to deal with
this virus
but what we've lacked is that collective
will across countries and between
countries to be
really comprehensive and sustainable in
the strategies and i believe that
populations and communities have become
confused by all of the changing
guidance
and
we've also had huge issues of trust um
not mislending everything that maria
said about vaccine inequity which is
probably the most
horrific
injustice of 2021
i hope and i pray that that can be
improved in in 2022.
thank you very much dr ryan next
question goes to byram altook from
honolulu news agency byram please unmute
yourself
thank you christian for taking my
question actually my question for mr ted
russ if i may please
turkey is a domestically developed
conflict 19 vaccine named tulkovac has
been approved
for emergency u.s health minister
fariton koja announced a couple hours
ago in turkey today and he said as of
today turkey have become one of the nine
countries producing a commitment in
vaccine in the world so how does the who
respond to this this to this
announcement and
when will wha pro the true cover crisis
produced
by turkey for emergencies thank you so
much and wish you all the best in 2022
thank you
thank you very much byram um i'll hand
this question to dr gaspar director
regulation and pre-qualification algeria
please
thank you so until now we had no
communication about that and no
interaction with any applicant regarding
turkovac what we can say is that from
our side as we always do we welcome all
the initiatives to develop vaccines that
could help
during this current public health crisis
provided that a number of standards and
requirements are met so
as soon as we have any interaction from
the applicant with who we will start to
engage and to discuss the conditions
that have to meet not only the applicant
but also the regulatory authority of
reference and there are published on who
website they are public and transparent
over geography
thank you very much
dr gaspar
i think that answers that one um next
question goes to jason bobian from npr
national public radio and jason please
unmute yourself
yeah thanks a lot for taking my question
i really appreciate it um with with the
omicron variant now out um how much
concern do you have
at the who about the effectiveness
particularly of the
non-mrna vaccines against it there have
been some early studies that that showed
very limited effectiveness of some of
these vaccines against this variant how
much concern is there and do you have
any more information about
how well some of the existing vaccines
are are working against this variant
thank you very much jason this goes to
dr sumiya swaminathan our chief
scientist
thank you tariq
i can start
well this is a question obviously that
that we're very interested in and that
sage the
strategic advisory group of experts and
immunization
is keeping a very very close eye on
as you know they are the committee that
advises who
on um
the policy for vaccines and they've been
making recommendations for each of the
vaccines that that we have uh provided
an emergency use listing for as you know
the novavax coverbacks vaccine
was the 10th
vaccine to receive emergency use listing
and sage guidance
these are all widely used of course
around the world
and
it is important
as each new variant has come along one
of the things who has done is to track
vaccine effectiveness
a lot of data is coming out on omicron
as it did for delta
and it is really important to have a
holistic view of vaccine performance
and not be
not have to make decisions based only on
early data which is usually
laboratory-based experiments looking at
neutralization assays
showing
almost consistently all of the lab
assays have shown a reduction
uh significant reduction
in neutralization
with the omicron variant which means
that
what it's indicating is that the omicron
variant needs much higher levels of
antibodies in the blood in order to
neutralize it
at the same time there have been studies
that have been looking at the other arm
of the immune system which is a t-cell
immunity or the cell-mediated immune
response
um
indicating that there is
uh protection that is likely to be
retained because the t cell responses
are against a much wider
range of
antigens on the spike protein and many
of those are not
have not been mutated in omicron so
chances are that there is still a good
amount of t-cell immunity
which
should reassure us that vaccines will
still continue to protect against severe
disease
and hospitalization
which is of course what we want vaccines
to do
now is there going to be a reduction in
vaccine effectiveness is this going to
be different you mentioned
mrna versus some of the others like the
viral vectored vaccines there are
inactivated vaccines being used
and now we have some new
uh subunit protein vaccines which have
still not been
used very widely they're just in a few
countries so far
so what we propose to do is to really
track
the clinical data i think that's really
important is we have to go beyond the
lab and really look at clinical data and
who has also
set up
a technical advisory group
to think about
the
potential for
changes in the strain
composition of vaccines
we know that a number of manufacturers
are already working
on omicron specific vaccines
um it's good to be proactive because we
don't know if we're going to need them
or not
but in the meantime who's tag kovac has
been meeting regularly
to develop the criteria for when
a vaccine strain change may be needed
and if so what should be that strain
what should be that consensus sequence
because you know even within omicron you
have a number of different
sequences of all of thousands of
sequences being uploaded so the
committee has to select
the consensus specific sequence that
manufacturers would need to use if
there is indeed a need
to switch vaccines and that would happen
if the current lot of vaccines are not
providing enough protection
we also today uh
published an interim guidance from sage
on boosters
and again there is now data and sage has
provided a lot of flexibility in
heterologous
uh regimens both for the primary course
as well as for the boosting so
uh
countries that have used
one particular type of vaccine let's say
a viral vector vaccine could opt to use
a different vaccine an mrna or a subunit
protein vaccine for example for a
booster dose if they chose to do so so
there is more and more data coming out
on on that as well but i think this is a
time of uh where the data is evolving
we're learning more and more it's
important that we do not conclude that
vaccines are ineffective at this stage
we've said repeatedly it's very unlikely
that a vaccine will become completely
ineffective clinically um because that's
not how vaccines usually act but
obviously we have to be uh driven by the
data and
our recommendations will change
accordingly based on the emerging
evidence
thank you tariq
thank you very much
dr swaminathan next question for
jenny fink from newsweek jenny please
unmute yourself
hi thank you so much for continuing to
do these briefings and taking the time
to answer my question um i'm just
curious so alpha beta and gamma have
been accounting for less than one
percent of sequence cases for a while
now and so i'm curious if omicron is as
transmissible as early data suggests
could it hinder
those variants ability to spread so much
that they're no longer variants of
concern and if
omicron's overtaking these
the other variants of concern
but
largely causes mild cases could this be
an example of what an endemic covid
would be like
thank you very much jenny and i'll give
to
marilyn van gaal um thanks for the
question so you indeed you're correct um
since october 20th uh less than point
one percent each of the sequences
uploaded to platforms like just aid um
have been alpha beta and gamma
96 of the sequences available are still
delta
and about 1.6 percent of sequences that
have been shared in recent weeks is
omicron
um we definitely see increasing growth
rates of omicron where it's being
detected
and it's now been reported in more than
106 countries to date
there's a combination of factors that we
think are leading to this increasing
transmission
first are the mutations that are
identified in the omicron variant
and we know something about these
mutations because some of these are
present in other variants of concern so
for example in omicron there are
mutations that allow the virus to adhere
to the cell
more easily and infect the cell more
easily
we also see immunoscape
where we see increasing rates of
re-infection
in in several countries
and then there's some preliminary data
that's looking at the efficiency and
replication of the omicron variant in
the upper respiratory tract as opposed
to the lower respiratory tract in the
lungs so this combination of factors um
is is likely leading to why we're seeing
increased growth rates in a number of
countries
in terms of how we classify variants of
concern and whether we change them we
have actually been having some
discussions about whether we need to
reclassify alpha beta and gamma
to change them from being called a
variant of concern to maybe a variant of
interest or they become variants of
monitoring strictly because they're not
circulating anymore
and because delta has out-competed those
variants
um the discussion that we've been having
is how we reclassify them and once you
have a variant of concern how do you
reclassify it as something else when in
fact the properties of that variant are
really what
allowed us to classify it as a variant
of concern
what we've done in our weekly epi
reports is we've shifted the way that we
present this information so that you
look at maps around where is the recent
detection of these variants because we
want to be able to put a time stamp in
terms of you know what is circulating
where um
but i think you know the virus is
changing um you've been hearing us say
that you know delta would not be the
last variance of concern that we would
speak about omicron is likely not going
to be the last variant of concern that
you hear us speak about as well because
the virus continues to continues to
circulate
um i don't think there's any question of
whether or not this virus will become
endemic it's certainly on its way to to
doing so
but endemic doesn't mean that it's not
dangerous you know endemic typically
means that has a lower level of
circulation and it's really
geographically bound to certain areas
and you'll see flare-ups where you see
unprotected populations and i think
we're on our way to that i don't think
anyone questions that but we're very
much still in the middle of a pandemic
um and we can't go into an endemic
situation part of the world where the
rest of the world is dealing with um
this in a pandemic type situation so i
think we're it'll there'll be a long
transition
um into how this pandemic ends until
into how we get into
what uh stars cov2 will look like going
forward it is a respiratory pathogen as
you know so we expect to see some kind
of seasonal variation you know just due
to behavioral factors but we haven't
seen that yet this virus thrives
wherever we allow it
and we don't get that reprieve in those
uh summer months or certain times of the
year
so there's still a lot of uncertainty of
how this virus would behave we expect
the virus to continue to evolve
we expect the virus to become
potentially more fit whether or not it
becomes more or less severe that remains
to be seen
we expect to see
populations that are vaccinated to have
significantly reduced morbidity and
mortality reduced amounts of
hospitalization reduced amounts of death
and we expect to see flare-ups um
depending how it will depend on how big
those flare-ups and those outbreaks are
as we go forward but they will occur in
under-protected populations people who
don't have vaccine um and people who are
don't yet have their full doses of
vaccines so i think there is some
understanding of where this virus is
going
but we remain humble to it because i
think it still has quite a few tricks up
its sleeve
thank you dr van kerkov and dr gaspar
our director regulation prequalification
to add on
just uh just a small letter to what
maria have said so wh show is monitoring
through two technical advisor groups who
attack ve for virus evolution and attack
kovac
for vaccine composition
and at the same time that who is
monitoring and preparing for any public
health responses that are needed
also behind the the scene the regulators
and the manufacturers are discussing the
scenarios that if one day needed to to
be upheld will be then deployed so just
to to say that most of the time the
general public doesn't know about the
work that is done behind scenes because
it's preparedness work looking at
scenarios extensively but just for
everybody to be
aware of that regulators worldwide
through ikmra the international
coalitional methods regulatory
authorities together with who and
specifically the regulatory advisory
group inside kovacs which is co-led by
sapi and who that meet regularly with
the cohort of those regulators foreign
we have been since the first day
discussing a number of scenarios if
needed to be implemented so the
preparation is there but we need to go
through the data as maria referred in a
systematic manner not taking decisions
too soon and certainly not taking
decisions too late and this is our
concern as the data is coming every day
thank you
thank you very much dr gaspar next
question goes to donato mancini from the
ft donato please unloot yourself
hi everyone thank you so much for taking
my question um
does omicron lend fresh support to the
pooling of intellectual property into
the trips waiver
negotiations for which have been
described as quote-unquote stuck
have you spoken to vaccine makers
recently after the emergence of omicron
about this and what have the
conversations been like obviously we
know that supply is easing and will
continue to ease unless there are
catastrophic scenarios in 2022 but are
you concerned
about omicron targeted vaccines if it
turns out that we need them thank you so
much
donato thank you very much i'll hand
over to our chief scientist
thank you for that question
donato i think the answer is
a yes it's it's obvious
uh this is something that who the
director general has been calling for
now
for a year and if we had seen that
sharing of technology the sharing of
know-how
let's say through the ctap
through the who's technology transfer
program
then maybe we would have had enough
vaccines today
even mrna vaccines
to have at least vaccinated all of the
healthcare workers in africa
and we know that three-fourths of them
are still waiting for vaccines
so clearly
this should have happened a long time
ago we've
said it in as many ways as possible
we have uh the dg has spoken with the
ceos
we have spoken with heads of state
um there's of course the parallel
process going on at the wto
where
i understand that there are still
negotiations uh that are going on of
course their in-person meeting was was
rescheduled
um
but at this point of time we have a
number of uh
second generation mrna vaccine so that's
the encouraging part that there are a
number of biotech companies around the
world
who have mrna vaccine technology that
they've developed which may even be
advantageous to the ones we have
currently being used today that are
willing to share the technology with us
but they are all at an earlier stage of
development just completing phase one
some of them completing phase two
we still need to go through the clinical
development pathway before they are
approved so we're looking at several
months down the line
and then to do the technology transfer
and to scale up manufacturing so
of course what we need right now is
technology transfer and we hope
that that we can still see that that
happening with the existing
vaccine platforms and and certainly mrna
has the advantage
of uh first of all of course
generating a very strong
immune response but also of being able
to
to pivot and to be able to tweak the
vaccine composition relatively
more easily than some of the other
uh platforms can do
um
they are more expensive and and they can
be more uh made more user-friendly in
terms of you know the temperature
storage and so on which which is what's
happening with the second generation
vaccines
but i think um
it's still not too late
and we would be very happy to work with
any company that wants to come in and
share the technology through the
mechanisms that who has set up
thank you and i wonder if the dg or
anyone else would like to add to that
i think very good thank you very much dr
swaminathan um next question goes to us
against somebody we haven't had yet
before i think
and that's ali for rescue from sky news
ali please unmute yourself
hello thank you for taking this question
you've called omicron an unprecedented
challenge and we've seen further
restrictions in many european countries
netherlands denmark ireland do you think
that the british government are unwise
to wait to see more data before going
further with restrictions in england
well we'll go to maria fancaco first and
then see maybe dr ryan
thanks for the question i mean i think
what we're omicron is is definitely you
know it's a variant that is anticipated
um as were the other variants of concern
that are emerging um i think our
recommendation has been not to wait to
act um you know the information that we
are receiving from south africa and
again we thank our colleagues there you
know who have been really tremendous and
and providing information almost in real
time as data are generated you know are
giving us some clues into how omicron is
behaving
it is a certain population it's a
different population delta was in low
level circulation
it is important to see how omicron
unfolds in other countries and we are
seeing that across the world right now
the big question is whether or not
omicron will out-compete delta
whether or not omicron and delta will
will co-circulate but you have to
remember that in europe europe was
seeing a huge wave of infections
that began in june and had been
increasing steadily since june
and we have repeatedly said um two
countries not just across europe but to
put in targeted layered approach uh
measures so that transmission can be
reduced and particularly as we lead up
to the holiday seasons where we see
people you know spending a lot of time
with each other as we enter the winter
months into the northern hemisphere will
people spend more time indoors and
outdoors um i think we've been very
clear on asking uh everyone you know
really to not wait to act um we also
appreciate that decisions that are made
are not just based on health or based on
other reasons as well um so we issue the
guidance we issue the considerations
that need to be taken but countries need
to take the decisions that they feel
are correct
what we are learning about omicron is
certainly we have this increased
transmission
but the information on severity
is still uncertain we don't have that
complete picture yet and it is too early
to conclude whether or not omicron is
less severe than delta or is as severe
as delta now we do have some
data suggesting that rates of
hospitalization are lower
some information that people who are
hospitalized
don't need as much oxygen or invasive
ventilation but again
we have not seen this variant
circulate for long enough
in populations around the world
certainly in vulnerable populations we
do we did learn some information this
week um that omicron as it enters older
age groups uh older people with omicron
tend to have more severe disease that's
unsurprising
we know people have died from omicron
it's too early to conclude
and i think that's really critical right
now because the data is a little bit
messy and it's not messy because there
aren't amazing scientists around the
world working on this it's just because
it's being generated right now
and so we have been asking
uh people to be cautious we've been
asking governments to be cautious um and
to really think you know especially as
these holidays are coming up um and
there are very difficult decisions as
the dg said on monday um you know there
are very difficult decisions that need
to be had in terms of making sure that
we keep ourselves safe there's plenty of
ways that we can celebrate holidays and
i know that none of this is ideal i
speak personally for myself and we've
made changes to our own hospital our own
holiday plans
um but these are difficult decisions
that we have to make uh each of us and i
hope more people are seriously
considering what they should do in their
own context and make the right decisions
for them but for us our
statements are around you know don't
wait to act um use a comprehensive
approach put in the measures that are
targeted that are layered that are
time-bound
um that are not locked down it doesn't
necessarily mean lockdown
and then adjust them as necessary as you
learn more as
the situation unfolds we won't be in
this situation forever
that we can certainly say um but it will
be difficult for the time being
thank you very much dr van kerkov and dr
mike ryan please
sorry i'm having difficulties um sorry i
know i i think maria has uh has really
answered that question
um extremely well and governments are
accountable
to their own population to provide
what they believe based on scientific
advice is the best uh
form
uh of care and the best strategy to
protect those individuals i just hope
in in this case that we're not again as
i said in my previous answer we need
comprehensive
layered responses that are we can turn
up and turn down as we need uh and not
necessarily panaceas or um you know hope
is in this case
is is is not a strategy we need to to
to be putting in place the necessary
measures to be able to reduce
transmission to the minimum while
recognizing and we need to recognize
this the
the inherent social and economic costs
of such measures and governments have to
balance both
and there is a difference between
science evidence and policy
policy comes when governments are able
to look at both the health economic and
social consequences of any of any
particular decision but it's certainly
from the perspective
we saw this last winter in many many
countries the idea of saying well we'll
see you know we'll do nothing now and
then we'll see what we do in the new
year
that certainly to me does not ring of an
approach that's science or
evidence-based
so i would much rather if governments
were to take the decisions they have to
take based on the evidence they see
before them taking into account the
social and economic consequences of
those decisions
thank you very much dr ryan and we'll
move to simon orteba from today news
africa simon please unlock yourself
thank you for taking my question this
i'm on a table with today news africa in
washington d.c
it's been six weeks since the umicron
variant was first detected in botswana
on november 11. i was wondering if you
can tell us how many confirmed cases of
the omicron variant
do we have now globally and especially
in africa
and how many debts have been directly
linked to the omicron variant globally
and if i may quickly add here in the u.s
despite despite president biden's ban on
only africans nation the omicron variant
has become the dominant version of covet
19 here
as you look back is this further proof
that outright bands are indeed not
effective not based on any sounds and
and only give us a false sense of
security thank you
thank you very much simon and dr van
kaku please
uh hi simon nice to hear your voice i i
actually cannot answer your question uh
with as much specificity as i was like i
would like in terms of how many cases of
omicron have there been how many deaths
have been due to omicron the reason for
that is because um to be able to detect
omicron we need sequencing
or we have a proxy with one of the tests
with this s gene drop out
so i don't have a number for you what i
can say is where it is circulating um
it's been detected in 106 countries um
many of those have been uh travel
related but we do know that there's a
bias right now because of of the
announcement of uh omicron as a variant
of concern
um the the amount of testing that's
happening among travelers or sequencing
among travelers also changes so the
picture is a bit mixed we do know that
there is some community transmission of
omicron in a number of countries
and we're tracking those and getting
information from a number of those
countries and we do know that people
have died
that people with omicron have died
so it is difficult to give an answer to
that because we don't have the complete
systems in place globally in terms of
linking surveillance for the pcr and the
antigen-based testing the links with the
uh sequencing of those people who have
tested positive from pcr tests or
antigen-based tests and having that
information reported to us so there's
also a time lag with that but it is
circulating and we do see the full
spectrum of disease with omicron
everything from asymptomatic
presentation asymptomatic infection all
the way through hospitalizations severe
disease and death the big question is
what is the proportion of those
individuals who are infected with this
variant um
that are mild that are asymptomatic or
that go on to severe disease and die
we do know
that people who are vaccinated
are have a much lower risk of developing
severe disease and death to both delta
and omicron so we stress the importance
of vaccination when it is your turn
regardless of what information we do
find out about omicron and the different
vaccines that are in use it is better to
be vaccinated than not so if you hear
anything from us today please hear that
and get vaccinated when it's your turn
and fight like hell for vaccine equity
for everybody else around the world
um i don't know if your second part of
your question was on travel was it on
restrictions is that right christian
um i mean certainly we have seen you
know the use of travel restrictions i
think we've answered this question many
times now
um in terms of the use of travel
restrictions and how they have been
applied particularly to this uh variant
um we do know that you know restricting
movement can delay but cannot stop uh
the spread of these types of variants
and and certainly as more omicron is
detected as sequencing is done
it's likely that this variant had been
circulating for a little bit of time at
least uh we don't know for how long
um but what has been you know quite
striking with this is the is the um
let's say inconsistent or a strange use
of travel restrictions
in this particular situation and
targeting only some countries that had
detected omicron versus not and what is
really critical for who is that we have
surveillance systems and reporting
systems based on trust that people know
that they can report this information
without being penalized and i think the
director general has been very very
clear
in his messaging around this and from
the organization around not penalizing
countries for reporting this type of
information
thank you very much dr van kerkov
next question and that might then just
be the last for today let's see how we
go about is for helen bransfeld from
stat news helen please unmute yourself
thank you very much christian and um
thank you for taking my question um
happy holidays to you all
um
i wanted to circle back if i could to dr
swami nathan's answer a few minutes ago
about the fact that the tag kovac is
working to develop criteria on uh that
could be used to determine when the
strain in the vaccine should be updated
and what
you know that strain ought to be when
that decision is made and i'm wondering
if you could tell me dr swami nathan
do you have buy-in from the
manufacturers that they will um take
part in
or follow the guidance of the w.h.o on
this
or
do you think at this point that they may
make their own decisions based on what
they see as an economic advantage
thank you very much herron and of course
dr swaminathan
thank you helen that's a very important
question and um
i think dr ryan may want to come in as
well because of the experience that who
has had
with
the influenza vaccine program whereas
you know it's the who
that provides the um
the strains for influenza vaccines for
the northern and southern hemispheres
every year
and
certainly the manufacturers
work with the who and and wait for the
who to pronounce that before they
actually go ahead
and make their vaccine so i think that's
really worked very well
now here we're talking about of course a
new virus
lots of unknowns
we have new platforms now the mrna
platforms
which clearly the manufacturers are able
to make these variant specific vaccines
and we know for example that
many of the manufacturers had
started making vaccines for
for beta for example for the beta
variant of concern
and and even for the delta
and so it's a question of making a
prototype
vaccine i think they've started
i do think that many manufacturers
want guidance from who
because of the fact that who has access
to a lot of information a lot of expert
groups
and expert advise
on what sequence or sequences
would be best
uh positioned to be in such a vaccine
um
but this is uh still an evolving
area just because
of the fact that you know
as maria was saying earlier this is not
we know this won't be the last variant
of concern
and if you have to make a decision
between going
with an omicron
consensus sequence
which is very far away from the original
uh mohan strain are you still going to
get that cross protection
um because tomorrow we may have another
strain that's closer to the original
heart strain and so on so there are lots
of questions and i think
what the committee's now going to dig
deep into is really looking at the
correlations between the genotypic
changes the mutations and the phenotypic
changes
and trying to come to an agreement
on which are the most critical changes
in the virus that you know
end up changing its phenotypic
properties whether it's transmissibility
or immune evasion and perhaps it's those
sequences that would need
to be included so that a future
vaccine could provide could provide
protection
but again it's complex there's only so
much you can do in a vaccine as you know
that there are limitations to what can
be done
and
and so i think what the committee is
also doing is actually inviting
manufacturers to their meetings and i
know that last time for example there
were at least
six manufacturers who participated in
their meeting and their meeting every
week
and so through this dialogue i think
there'll be a much better understanding
and and i think it's important that the
who committee
which has been tasked with this should
really be the one that tells the world
uh
what vaccine sequences what sequences
should be used
for uh for targeting and of course then
we also have new generation vaccines uh
coming along and other types of vaccines
like the nasal vaccines and so on so at
the same time
and the dg mentioned the solidarity
vaccines trial that has basically been
set up
in order to test the vaccines that have
still not gone through phase three and
generate enough data including you know
on the nasal vaccines and so on
so that we can think about
we can generate more data on whether
those are being more effective so
i don't know if i've answered your
question entirely but i'm sure that as
the committee continues to meet and
deliberately put out
their their the minutes from their
meetings as well as their guidance
from time to time
thank you daddy
thank you dr swaminathan and dr ryan
please
and
season's greetings to you as well
um
you know and i think
we have been i mean rogerio was on
earlier i mean there's a huge
collaboration going on between
regulators the research and development
blueprint for epidemics continues to
engage thousands of scientists from
around the world on the upstream
research regarding uh you know what we
understand about the this new variant
what we understand in terms of vaccine
and what may be needed in terms of new
target product profiles for for any uh
evolution of vaccine we have the tag for
virus evolution which is really tracking
the work working with us to track the
evolution of the virus and then
obviously the the tag coax which is
really looking at covet vaccination and
composition of vaccines and that's very
much aligned and
in parallel to the work we do on an
influenza which i know you're you're
very well aware of um the tychovac i
think has over 30 experts on it these
people are vastly experienced uh both in
terms of what we do in flu but also what
we do in corona
viruses um and as soon as i said
correctly they're really looking now at
one of the phenotypic
behavior of this virus how it behaves in
the real world energetically to see
whether or not the current vaccines are
providing the levels of protection that
they need to and again a lot of the data
up to now has been protection against
infection not protection against severe
disease hospitalization and death which
vaccines were really set up to prevent
so we still have to see what that is but
that doesn't mean we shouldn't be doing
work in the meantime the tagover hand
will meet again tomorrow
and we'll also meet again tomorrow with
the manufacturers to have that continued
discussion um and again if we cast our
minds to the you know 70 year history of
influenza surveillance around the world
this is truly truly truly a partnership
between science between member states
and the private sector and the
manufacturing uh
pharmaceutical companies and
everyone plays their part
and twice a year
we get together with all of that data
all of those scientists and then create
a selection of vaccine composition which
is then passed on to manufacturers and
manufacturers are absolutely outstanding
in the way that they engage with who
with our advisory groups on that work
and we believe that we help
[Music]
people for getting the right composition
of vaccine we also help manufacturers by
creating a very transparent process of
selecting the the strains for each
year's vaccine for north and south
allowing all manufacturers to
participate in an equal footing
and we believe now there are many many
potential manufacturers out there for
public vaccines as well and and also so
we are referred to to some of the new
vaccines that are in trial
about nasal vaccines and non-injectable
vaccines
and other things so we need to have the
manufacturing world the pharmaceutical
world now is much broader than it was in
terms of for these vaccines for now and
for going forward and it's really
important that we engage with the
broadest range of manufacturers and
create that level playing through that
transparency around what who and its
experts believe
are the most
effective designs for vaccines and in
the short term looking at
varying specific vaccines or
combinations of those and again assuming
you said looking in the longer term at
new vaccine platforms and new types of
vaccines that may give more conservative
protection against a broader range of
epitopes
in terms of the the virus itself so
there's both work to do in the short
term and the long term but again we
right now and as if if we lurch into
producing omicron specific vaccines we
could lose effectiveness against
currently circulating strains as well so
i think casper put it
right here put us really well we have to
be fast enough to make a good decision
but at the same time we have to be able
to consider all of the relevant data so
it's finding that
combination of
careful consideration of the data and
making that decision on time to be able
to give the right information to
industry
to be able to produce the appropriate
vaccines and this needs to be a strong
and deep deepening partnership between
the public the private the academic
sector in order to get these decisions
made in the most timely way
thank you so much dr
ryan now
we come to the end of this briefing i
thank you all for your participation a
quick
note um
we are trying to give you all a break
for next week and did not schedule a
regular press briefing yet
but as you know things are constantly
developing so if there's a need we will
call upon you but for now the plan is to
give you a week
off so to say for next week um that
means this was the last briefing of this
year and i thank you all very much for
being with us for this whole year and
thanks to the translators here
who've been with us too um we'll be
sending the audio files and dr tetra's
remarks right after the press conference
as usual the full transcript will be
posted on the w h o web site tomorrow
morning after this thank you and over to
dr tenders thank you thank you christian
and i just have
one correction from the statement i read
earlier
where i say the global priority must be
to support
all countries to reach the 40 percent
target as quickly as possible
and the 70 percent target by the middle
of next year not this year so i said
this year i'm sorry for that 70 target
is for next year
and then
maybe just one
issue uh
you know we had the first question
actually
um
about the virus and what do we know and
what the challenges are
i think
two years we know the virus better now
and based on that we have
very effective tools
and going forward
there is hope and that's why my
statement said we should end this
pandemic
by
you know 2022.
the reason for that is because i have
and we have as wh of confidence that we
know the virus now very well and we have
all the tools the issue is
implement all the tools we have as
you know comprehensively
vaccines plus the other
public health
measures
and when we do that we should also
take care of equity because unless
we vaccinate the whole world unless we
apply the comprehensive approach all
over the world i don't think we can end
this pandemic but i think
i would repeat again we know the virus
better we have effective tools
and we need to add to that comprehensive
implementation and equity
and hope 20 to 22
will
end this pandemic so thank you again and
i would like to wish all who celebrated
a very merry christmas
merry christmas and see you in our
upcoming presser thank you
you